um how many books have you put out
because this is i don't know what is
this like the tenth or something
yeah it's around there um i have like
maybe eight or nine
real legit books and then i have um some
books that
was just a compendium or compilation of
my best blog posts
i don't consider those books there's
three of those out there uh
but yeah that's that's a we're coming up
on ten yeah not ten it's nine or eight
yeah
cool so um what was the motivation
behind the book of numbers
uh it was economics and uh i know you
honorarily gave me my phd in economics i
appreciate that from ryerson university
uh but yeah the main thing was economics
where um
if you look at it the vast majority
of current and historical economic
production in innovation and creation
was
by men and i had a very simple question
like
well if we take away the number one
thing that incentivizes men to work
which would be
pretty attractive women what would be
the economic ramifications and
furthermore or more specifically on the
individual level
is uh men spend the majority
of their time energy and resources it's
the ultimate economic question they
pursue it
chasing women and i said okay given
today
the environment and women's interest in
marriage or children and all that other
stuff not to mention some
um statistics about you know how
successful
the average man can expect to be is
men essentially spending their entire
lives
worth the pursuit of women like you know
is this is this so i i did the
first cost benefit analysis on the
pursuit of women and that's
that's what i wanted to do and the
ramifications are huge
and uh you know everyone's like kind of
tongue-in-cheek like oh look he did
a roi in women how cute is that i'm like
no there's there's some
larger global i do mean global
economic consequences that if frankly
women are
fat uh mean
disagreeable uh you are
tanking you're you're pouring like sugar
or salt into the
the gas tank of the economic engine of
the world and men are just
not going to produce as much as they
would have
had they been guaranteed through
societal norms of conventional a wife
and children
and so um that that was the larger
economic and
right now as as i think everybody knows
it's kind of a
an interesting wow how edgy like no
there's some there's some consequences
where
if all sudden you know what accounted
for
90 of real gdp and i will say this i'll
state this
nearly 100 of all technological
innovation men
what happens if they shut down you know
if they have no incentive and they
they decide to like yeah i'll just stay
at home or i'll be a neat or something
like that so
that is what that's what uh prompted me
to write this book is it's an economic
analysis that it's also a question i
post it meant like hey
is this worth your time long story short
it really isn't though
yes we don't have to read through it
right yeah there we go and good night
everybody good luck
yeah i mean like i think we already have
the answer to this i mean it's it's
it's not the best use of a man's time to
to to
throw a lot of time effort money and
resources but
the book itself breaks down why and the
underlying notion
behind that it's like the foundation of
all of that so you can get the mechanics
of it
i think men generally speaking are more
rational deductive logical
problem solvers so the book of numbers
deals with all the elements that
lead up to it's really not a good use of
your time if you throw a lot of time
effort and resources at this right
right and i i think everybody knows i
mean we kind of like ha ha ha
it's negative and everyone says what's
the roi so even positive and so
i think we all understand that but also
what i wanted to achieve with this book
was doing a a breakdown of the
statistical analyses and like
look here are some hard numbers and some
of them are within an era of range i'm
not saying these are like you know
precise it's a social science so there's
always room for error
but i think uh two things one to give
men both old and young like some numbers
like look if you're going to go and
gamble in this house
here your statistics here are your odds
and the other thing
uh for guys like you me you know
old-timers terrence popp who've gone
through hell
to look at and say is this is there
something wrong with me did i do
something wrong and i'd like to you know
put this out there that book saying no
it ain't there
unless you're like a jerk or there's
something wrong with you actually
generally
wrong with you but for most men no it's
not your fault and so it's to deliver a
bit of
sanity uh to men out there who have gone
through hell
who have gone through the you know
trials and tribulations of dating
western women in general to say like
look no it
the the numbers are on your side and it
doesn't solve the problem i mean
june cleavers are not going to be
mass-produced anytime soon but at least
you know it wasn't your fault
and so uh there's an element of
forgiveness that i like to
to promote that book with
yeah there's um i mean you went through
my book and i and i collected some data
on um the success rates of long-term
relationships and marriages and one of
the things i
i came across in a study uh was i think
it was something like
three percent of couples after eight
years they're living in a state of like
bliss or obsession for one another and i
believe that the uh data was something
like
12 or 13 something like about 12 and a
half percent
um we're still living in a state of love
for one another the rest of them weren't
it's it's it's it's just not like that
old fairy tale that you think that
you're going to sign up for when you're
watching
disney and gilligan's island when
they're all fawning over the girls and
all that stuff
it's that's not the reality of the world
in the way that things usually pan out i
mean
you can't have a good experience but you
need
all of these things to fall in place to
make that happen the way that you wrote
the book though i
noticed that when you kind of put it
together you were talking about this
from the perspective of the average
joe why did you why did you bring it
down to the average joe level like why
did it have to be like the average guy
because because of uh applicability um
i know you me other people that tune in
were probably
on the right side of the build
distribution curve but uh i wanted to be
applicable to your average american
western male
uh the other what does that avatar look
like is that like a guy that works a
nine to five job
uh yeah ryan stone you know ryan
i'm just busting his balls no you're and
it's to be
uh you bring up a good point because no
the average guy is not
us not not to swing my dick around but
frankly
no the average guy is not me it's not
you this is to be the average guy so be
very applicable the other problem that i
ran into richard
was like to run scenarios and run
statistics
i had to say like okay we need a a
subject
we need a uh a test subject and so
i'm gonna run with average joe five and
so
all the not all but a lot of the
statistical analyses were done like okay
here's this guy he's an average looking
guy
average income what does the average man
look to get now interestingly enough i
do have the model i could tweak it like
okay let's say you're a nine
or let's say you have this type of
income i haven't programmed height into
it because frankly it's
intangible to to program into it uh but
that that was the reason why i focused
on the
another example is a lot of people would
say i define
success as happily married well a lot of
guys don't want to get married
but that has been the traditional uh
metric by which we would consider
success so there were in order to
do some analyses and crunch some real
numbers
i had to make some assumptions that
would not apply to everyone
but it was the average guy looking to
get married and be happily married till
death do impart and i know that's
idealistic and it's not
the entire case but i thought that would
be the most applicable and universal and
relatable
when i did that analysis
you